الفعل هناك صعوبه في الاتصالات وخصوصا في
الانترنت والكهرباء كانت بلديه همم
والسلطات هنا في خرسون اعاده التيار
الكهربائي قبل يومين الى مستوى 50% من
طاقته من طاقته الى المنازل ولكن قصف
الامس وقذف اليوم تعرضت المدينه لقصف هذا
الصباح وتتعرضت ايضا لقصف عند منتصف الظهر
ما ادى الى قطع التيار الكهربائي عاد
المستوى القطع الى ما كانت عليه قبل 10
ايام لذلك انقطاع التيار الكهربائي هو
الانقطاع للتدفئه عن التدفئه انقطاع
لشبكات ومحطات داخل المياه وانقطاع ايضا
همم الانترنت تقوم السلطات قامت بمبادره
ومشروع يسمى هنا بكم مشروع نقطه الصمود او
نقط عدم الانكسار هو عباره عن خيم يتم
وضعها في وسط المدينه في بعض المدن هنا في
خيرسون هذا الصباح توجهنا الى احدى القيام
هناك ثلاث ايام تم وضع في الخيم همم وعلى
نفس الساحه حيث تتواجد الخيام تم هناك وضع
انترنت عبر الستالايت عبرنك لذلك يجي
الكثير من السكان الى هناك بدايه للانترنت
ولكن في هذه الخيم هناك تدفئه هناك
ايضا كهرباء بامكان شحن شحن بطاريات هواتف
فين بامكانهم ايضا الاتصال عبر الانترنت
مع اصدقائي تحدثت الى العديد من الاشخاص
الموجودين هناك
والجميع الفئات السكان كان هناك طلاب من
الجامعه يلتقون للدراسه سواء كانت دراسه
عن بعد او للواجبات المدرسيه